contender may be all set to make their
mark on the digital console age as they
filed a patent for a diskless system the
company filed a patent back in February
of this year but it was only discovered
by Neoga this week the application reads
an example system includes an internal
hard disk drive during a program and/or
data a communication unit transmitting
receiving a program and order sapphire
and network and a processor executing a
program stored in the hard disk drive to
perform game processing the example
system is not provided with an optical
disc drive for reading out the program
and for data from an optical disc that
legal speak for no physical disk drive
included that said an accompanying image
suggested that there is indeed a card
slot Nintendo is not confirmed whether
the patent has anything to do with their
upcoming and expose all let me know down
in the comments if you be keen on a
difficult system and why or why not be
sure to stay tuned to gamespot for all
the latest